it's not a frequent occurrence that I'm
at a loss for words I usually have words
or at least I can come up with a few to
sort of throw at you through my
microphone every single day but I really
sort of don't know how to introduce this
first story today to you I mean never
mind how to analyze it right but even
how to tell you about it
Saturday Donald Trump said that he had a
phone call with an official from the
North Korean Security Council the call
was actually with the South Korean
president moon jae-in does Trump not
know that he spoke to the South Korean
president and he thought he was talking
to someone from North Korea did he make
up the entire thing does this connect to
the story about dementia or is it a
story about lying or of confusion and
incompetence Donald Trump told the story
they called up a couple of days ago we
would like to talk and I said so would
we but you've got to de nuke you have to
de nuke of course that was a phone call
not with the North Korean Security
Council official but with the South
Korean president who as far as the world
knows doesn't have nuclear weapons and
later we heard confirmation that the
President did not have a phone call with
North Koreans but apparently was
characterizing his phone call with the
South Korean president so first of all
one possibility is Trump doesn't know
the difference between the leaders of
North and South Korea that would be
grounds for removing him from office
right if he's on the phone thinking he's
doing diplomacy with North Korea and
he's talking to the South Korean
president that would be immediate
grounds for dismissal for the president
number two South Korea doesn't have
nuclear weapons that we know of if on
the phone Trump is referring to you
really have to de nuke and he's talking
to moon jae-in either moon jae-in thinks
this guy's incompetent which would be
accurate or if on the off chance that
South Korea has some kind of secret
stash of nuclear weapons moon jae-in
thinks wow
the gig is up Donald Trump somehow this
is the guy who has figured out that
we're actually hiding nuclear weapons
unless North Korea unless South Korea
rather is secretly a nuclear state then
there are real problems here and then
the other possibility which I sort of
alluded to before could trump have made
up the entire thing that he said he
spoke to North Korean officials but he
really didn't speak to anyone like he
literally just concocted the entire
thing thing out of thin air and then of
course lastly it's the possibility of
dementia which is know during the call
Trump did know he was talking to the
South Korean president moon jaein
he later remembered the conversation as
having been with an official from the
North Korean Security Council where he
said that they've got to get rid of
their nukes that shockingly the most
charitable explanation from this that I
gather would be it's dementia and Trump
was okay during the call but just can't
remember what the hell went on because
all of the others are either
incompetence to a degree that justifies
removal from the office of President or
number two absolute and total
fabrication of a phone call that never
take took place my hope is that there
was no call at all right my hope is that
the phone on Donald Trump's desk in the
Oval Office has been replaced with one
that only rings in the next room over
and people in the White House are sort
of acting and playing roles so that
Trump thinks he's actually talking to
world leaders and somebody else is
actually handling the conversations with
world leaders and the part that hasn't
been reported here is that Trump's
confusion was actually that he thought
he was on the phone with the Chinese
restaurant and he couldn't understand
why moon jae-in just would not give him
the crab rangoon and he was very very
visibly angry after this I'm begging for
the transcript right i if the phone call
took place I want to see where Donald
Trump supposedly said to moon jae-in of
South Korea which doesn't have nuclear
weapons that they need to de nuke and we
also have to consider that that other
option that I mentioned before
which is there was no call at all with
anybody from either Korea and Trump made
the entire thing up and then again it
would be one of those demonstrably
falsifiable lies of sort of only passing
political benefit that we wonder why
would somebody be stupid or narcissistic
enough to even lie about that the video
you just finished watching was made
possible by you through the membership
program you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership we
are viewer supported independent media
you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership